no our sex is right there's that oh god
stop that's not fun sounds nice yeah the
post or post partum poop and sex is
something I am definitely dreading hey
guys I'm Allie sharp welcome to Abby's
kitchen and I'm here with my friend Abbi
Langer so excited to be here again
yes so Abbi is a mom two beautiful girls
and I'm about to become a mom so if you
go on the internet nowadays there are so
many mom hacks out there designed to
make life a little bit easier for us
parents right what parent doesn't want a
hack
yes just make their day a little bit
easier yeah we're busy we've got crazy
things going on we're trying to get work
done we're trying to change diapers
we're trying to get a meal on the table
we need some help we do so we scoured
the internet finding some great
parenting hacks and we came across a few
that were a little bit questionable
right I mean I'm not totally ruling them
out if they help us great I'm all for it
but I'm a little bit skeptical me too
yeah so let's try them out okay so our
first hack comes from the world of
Facebook it's called the blooming
marshmallow so this was actually brought
to me from one of my mom friends because
her daughter insisted she make it for
her and so basically it's a nice way to
make your daughter or sons hot chocolate
a little bit more interesting a little
more fun a little more festive
marshmallow yeah and I was trying to
bloom in my hot chocolate well it's
amazing yeah let's take a look and see
what's involved all right so you make me
marshmallows and then we're just gonna
spread out that melted marshmallow
situation you basically have to be a
professional pastry chef yeah that sort
of smooth oh she's stamping out the
shape oh and that's a face because
everybody has a flower never dance again
all right melt away to that sauce cut in
a sauce cup what the hell is this oh oh
and then you've got like a little white
chocolate cup and then you just like
submit it should I put some little tray
Jai's balls in there well it looks
amazing
uh oh wow that's actually really cool
yeah you know what tax like these are
amazing because when your kids are
getting really annoying something like
this really occupies that oh yeah I mean
definitely anything that's gonna like
get them excited
well it's chocolate so why aren't they
already excited they should be excited
we just played guys but let's let's do
this for us
I want to eat all right let's make this
all right as per the video instructions
we have microwaved our marshmallows and
we're going to add this
oh god this is already getting really
frustrating they didn't show this step
yeah they never taste but hey no they
never show the struggle
alright so already I'm thinking hey kids
just be happy with some in your and your
budget on the list to do this you should
be grateful they're you getting any
chocolate up we go turn that baby on
yes actually kind of cool oh and that's
a great way that get your kids
disgustingly messy right okay so we're
gonna try to start to get this head AB
if you want to take this spoon and try
to get whatever the hell is in the
bottom of that bowl marshmallow I know
everywhere I don't know how she did this
and it's just like crazy honestly look
get it okay this is this is like a five
person job all right I know honestly oh
my god I'm sticking everywhere this
isn't as much as I'm gonna do because I
could be here all day just trying to
spread this should I open it just gonna
make it worse but this into the freezer
through it alright so here we are
step two it's come out of the freezer
we've got enough to make two flower
blooming marshmallows so once you give
that a go start to try it your best -
yeah it's me oh my god okay wait I got
it okay don't worry No okay so why don't
we you okay try it again
number two twice three times nope
okay no I don't think so just cut like a
circle and we'll make that work well I
work on the white chocolate so I stole
these from McDonald's ooh a little
sketchy not gonna lie but it was worth
it
right this is the only way you can get
these tiny little Dixie Cups I'm unaware
of where else you can purchase these so
legitimately purchase them so I'm just
putting a little bit of melted white
chocolate I can melt this in the
microwave this was a whole other step of
course okay try to like squeeze it in
there is best you've been talking about
no you gotta leave in there so we gotta
fit it in fridge again or the next step
before so you can bloom it's blue oh no
I'm stuck okay I have faith this is
gonna work out okay forget it no no no I
want to see this come to fruition buy
these
research okay so the next step is to
peel this and then uncover the white
chocolate shell underneath apparently I
already feel like I'm gonna eat pieces
of plastic or pipe paper it's really
hard to get in here yeah I realize about
these hacks when you watch the videos
there's so many steps they're not
showing know for sure like the struggle
the struggle in every step
yeah like this like the fact that the
paper is sticking to the bullet all
right let's see a bloom Wow Wow so what
we have is some white chocolate with
some marshmallow
I mean it's so good yeah it's
marshmallow but like we could have just
put good marshmallow on top watch I'm
gonna enjoy this I mean how could you
not hot chocolate and marshmallows but
we went through hell like actual hell
yeah I think I need to see a
psychologist after this I need to ask
aspect girl a few questions no they're
all what we saw no will be saw not well
we know what we were anticipating so I'm
grossly disappointed grossly okay so for
our next hack we're gonna learn how to
make peanut butter sandwiches even
easier and faster aren't they the
easiest thing to me I thought so that
was my impression but I guess I was
thinking hey motherhood must be really
[ __ ] hard it's really not that okay
well I'm glad to hear that you're you're
definitely making me feel a little
little better about what I'm walking
into but let's take a look at what what
we can learn from our friend Bev widenar
okay so nice sexy honey drizzle shot
what no more tour breath oh we're trying
bread okay I guess that's a first world
problem right there oh so she's okay so
she's got some parchment paper down but
peanut butter that's that spreadable is
not gonna tear your bread anyway if
you're rolling it out and now we're
going to the freezer so we have a
multi-day process on our hand I know why
people laughed at this because this is
ridiculous
oh my god okay
see ya we deserve Trump yes yes I don't
think I've ever seen an entire you do
comment section agree on something this
video might just be the secret to
uniting the country a men Oh wonder how
this makes toast good point I mean if
this woman complicates scene of our
sandwiches like this I would hate to see
what she does to like boxed cake or mac
and cheese I mean she is going down if
this woman's gonna make mac and cheese
she needs parenting hi oh this is the
way she yeah I can't imagine how she
gets by in a day okay let's try let's do
it
all right so Abby I'm excited to try
this little hack here but I feel like
you need to up the ante yeah so you're
gonna do the traditional peanut butter
sandwich you're gonna make as many
peanut butter sandwiches as you can with
just a knife peanut butter and bread and
I'm gonna make it babs way perfect ready
let's do it let's go
all right so we got a load here just
like that does all right oh god you're
already beating me I have even done step
one yet okay oh my god this is heavy
Oh God looks like it looks like it got
stuck between a few colored paper
I guess that the mom hack in itself like
how do you roll your rich houses through
that but now it's coming up again so you
gotta get used to the food spills a
explosive poops Oh God
oh there we go and poop everywhere are
you having a snack me I haven't even
finished this one that looks a dog pill
yep mmm look at the freezer all right
all right so our freezer peanut butter
is ready to go now for the next step is
we cut some nice squares we make it
pretty gotta make it perfect for our
children yes let's make a couple
sandwiches okay here's your square
Thanks
here's my square this is already looking
very messy oh so yeah that didn't work
because it melted so fast yeah so I
don't know this happened on hack on hack
not hack but but you know for snacking
perfect great yeah mm-hmm all right
onca nightclub how is this gonna work
all right so our third hack is this
threaded spaghetti hot dog bites that we
found on Pinterest pin it I would
probably be embarrassed to do that is so
I it looks like when you put together
for Halloween yeah scare your children
like they look I'm scared just looking
at it but er yeah a little bit it's
disturbing I'm not sure but basically
it's a hack because you get to have two
of your favorite kids foods in one dish
it's a one-pot wonder don't serve
spaghetti with hot dogs serve it in hot
dog honestly I am all for a hot dog and
I love my pasta but the idea of putting
it together in a meal that's wrong it's
wrong I can see my my Italian producer
here is like throwing up in the mouth
yeah just imagining what's we're what
we're gonna put together yeah so let's
try it
I'm have I'm an open mind I have an open
mind yeah we you know I know kids like
hot dogs kids like spot spaghetti maybe
my kids would love that
they might there we go so this makes it
easy yeah all right so now we thread a
few pieces of spaghetti through each of
these
it looks like she's it's like Oh see
this is already telling me to leave that
one in there
Oh Oh God okay that's fine failing bread
you gotta be good deliberate and very
gentle with the very good job I keep
breaking the spaghetti I'm hurt I think
okay let's get some boiling water going
yeah come on get the food porn thud it
smells gross in a nostalgic way all
right hey hey we said we would get this
a try it's Mia Forks yeah how do you eat
this with that it like dripping on you
[Music]
so by the time the hot dog cooked
through the pastas still out Dante
yeah and it's the ketchup with pasta I
don't know maybe some of you guys out
there like ketchup with your pants I
hope you hope you guessed it if you do
please just unsubscribe right now oh
okay but we won't be doing that one for
our kids that's for sure that's on the
list that's not to do alright so for our
last hack we are going to look at Glenn
I found on YouTube about parenting hack
that makes dipping Oreos in milk easier
and cleaner so that you don't have to
get your fingers apparently into the
milk you just well you're gonna see
let's make a useful hack useful yes all
right let's take a look
starts right here got some poor use
glass of milk classic combo okay yeah go
without how could you make this any oh
okay so we we put a fork in into the
cream in the middle then you bite the
Oreo break your two
that was my first thought it's like mmm
how easy and fun is biting into a nice
hard piece of metal so I would like to
try this myself because I'm all for any
excuse to eat Oreos yeah yes so here's
some milk and some Oreos this is it
really I'm excited about this one I
saved this one for a decision for the
Double Stuf I definitely should have
actually now that I see I feel like look
like it's already kind of falling off
dunking yes and so we have the choice
here we can bite into the metal or we
can take it off and then get our fingers
dirty again from the milk Lee I just
don't understand this is I just don't
bite all the way through but then it's
gonna break like look oh come on uh-huh
I put into it
now what especially kids kids would
fight it oh for sure and then you would
get like a chipped tooth that you then
had to deal with and you get a crying
child you get like a fork and in mouth
and you get kids fighting with the forks
find them with the Oreos yeah like on
guard I can see this becoming like a
yeah right to the death I got a duel
with that it's definitely not worth it
it's not gonna save you any time no it's
actually gonna give you another thing to
leave dirty cutlery yep well Abbi I
don't think our life got any easier
today no you know add a lot more
disgusting disgusting more expensive
more time-consuming or depressing I'm
gonna be in therapy for months after
eating that spaghetti with the with the
[ __ ] hot dogs situation it's just not
good yeah so if you guys have any
legitimate parenting hacks I definitely
want to hear from you in the comments
below tell me what is gonna help me as a
new mom also don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and give this video the
big thumbs up if you liked it and I hope
to see you next time on Abby's kitchen
bye
you
[Music]